[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine and this week
we're talking about hot eggy and the
concepts of hot eggy eggy literally
translates as belly power the strength
that comes out of the belly and it's
called that because of the kinds of
alignments and mechanics we're gonna use
in order to do that and the strongest
position we can be generally is with
their hands right here in front of our
belly in front of our Hara if I'm
dealing with someone having them there
for me is the strongest position I can
have and if I can shift myself away from
their center that's what I want
we're going to look at a classic Aikido
demonstration of how to eat and talk
about how that works with some of the
principles we've already explored this
week all right so here we're going to
have a classic icater demonstration so
she's going to use some Huta ghee in
order to do this she's gonna use a lot
of the principles that we just discussed
right
so one principle she's gonna use is
she's gonna lengthen the leverage that
those guys have to deal with right so
they're gonna she's going to move
herself really far away from those kind
of lifting and she's also going to cause
them to house some distraction in the
force that are putting in so first thing
we're gonna do is have you guys go ahead
with Sasha
I'm pretty easy for them to do that this
time when Sasha doesn't or when we do it
we're gonna have to flip some shops and
some she's gonna force herself down so
these guys are done really is to keep
her up in the air to keep her up so go
ahead and get it right up in the air all
right so I want you to bring yourself
down all right so now it seems
miraculous and magic because sasha was
already up in the air they have the big
advantage under and yet somehow she's
able to come down the way she's able to
do that she's disconnecting them from
her Center so it makes it hard for them
to live to her Center and she's reaching
out extending that lever so it's hard
for them to hold up so if someone to
keep herself on the ground she could do
that too so if these guys king tried to
pick her up now by using those same
techniques so she can keep herself with
ever getting up on the ground
they're both struggling really hard
right now they're gonna be out breathitt
as they can do people feel safe return
but this is the way that Sasha can keep
herself on the ground by disconnecting
her center from the way they're pushing
so again it looks like a miraculous
thing it and we can tell you all kinds
of magical powers or something to be had
but the truth is simply that sausage
using good mechanics glute leverage and
honey and we keep my body connected the
way she wants order to do these things